police in hong kong have arrested media
tycoon jimmy ly
an outspoken critic of china's policies
in hong kong
a top aide said lai is being held over
suspected
collusion with foreign forces under the
controversial national security law
imposed by beijing in june
the 71 year old owns popular tabloid
apple daily
he's one of seven people police said
they arrested during raids
on monday well for the very latest let's
cross over to
hong kong where our correspondent phoebe
collin is standing by phoebe
this is the most high profile arrest so
far
under the new security law imposed by
beijing what more can you tell us
the operation is wide-ranging today not
only jimmy lyon was
was under arrest but also a number of
senior management staff were arrested
as well for charges relating to
committing fraud
so while we we don't have uh much
details about the accusation but the
operation today is huge
uh police have deployed a huge number of
offices to conduct a raid hundreds of
officers
are now working inside the media
headquarters and it's expected to last
for a while
for the rest of the day and um also
outside
the premises we heard that a number of
uh media
including foreign media like um like
many news agencies
were blocked from uh were blocked by the
police from reporting
uh uh outside the building and also to
attend oppressor so
we can have a sense of like how the uh
intense atmosphere we have
today and especially uh many think
this could be alarm to the past freedom
in hong kong
so this sounds like part of a wider
crackdown on
the media tell us more about who exactly
jimmy lye
is and why his arrest is so important
well jamilai is a media tycoon who owns
and founded
apple daily newspaper like which is the
largest
local media organizations uh which is
critical of the government
and also not only the hong kong
governments but also the beijing
government
so jimmy himself personally he
is outspoken about his political stance
he often like attends rallies and
protests
on his own capacity he has
he has also been arrested for for other
charges relating to
our protests and demonstrations before
but this time he was like arrested under
the national security law
uh and and he's the most high profile
arrestee so far
and uh but for the apple daily
organization it has long been criticized
by the state media of beijing
and authorities that um they are
accusing the government and are blaming
the government for many social problems
so
they are definitely like for that case
not so welcomed by the authorities
now the police raid on jimmy lie's
offices were
live streamed how are people in hong
kong
reacting to the news of his arrest
well this is uh definitely a shocking
like a piece of shocking news to many in
hong kong
although uh it's uh widely expected that
jimi lai would be targeted
under the national security law as
beijing authority and state media
has already stated earlier that um jimi
lai is suspected of the kuru
of committing some of the offenses under
the security law but
today we see the uh the the spectrum
and the scope of the operation that
shocked many people
and the journalists association a
journalist association in hong kong
and the chairman have condemned the
operation and saying that it could send
a more serious
shielding in fact across the city
especially to the journalists
that even for those who were not
arrested today but they may be afraid to
speak out in the future
phoebe thank you very much that update
that's our correspondent phoebe kong in
hong kong
publishing books in hong kong hasn't
been easy for a while
especially one about last year's
protests for publisher raymond yang
the new chinese security law has changed
everything about his current project
a collection of articles written by
thousands of people who took part in the
demonstrations
raymond and his team have been taking
out words and pictures
that could cross the red line they have
even changed the book cover
these tags on pages mark some of the
so-called taboos
most of the political slogans were
removed such as the popular protest
slogan
liberate hong kong revolution of our
times which has recently been declared
illegal we also deleted the paragraphs
which may advocate or imply
succession but no one can tell us how
exactly the red line is drawn
not even lawyers it's the most painful
project i've done
the book was to have been published two
months ago but that still hasn't
happened as five printers
have rejected it because of the
sensitivity
some ask raymond to change part of the
content that rarely happened in the past
distributors and bookstores also turn it
down
beijing's weeping law is not only
deterring new publications
but is also affecting older ones jimmy
peng
a veteran publisher who has worked in
the industry for over
three decades has also felt its effects
he has suspended further publication of
a book released last year
to mark the 30th anniversary of the 10
month square crackdown
the remaining copies won't be put on
display at book fairs
anymore
this is the biggest crisis facing the
whole industry everyone is anxious
we don't want to be revolutionaries but
to uphold free speech and promote
knowledge
what quality do our citizens have if
diversity and enlightening ideologies
vanish
that's hard to restore once they're lost
what's going on in hong kong is more
than self-censorship
at least nine books written by
opposition fakers have been removed from
public libraries
in order to review whether they breach
the new law schools have also been
ordered to do the same
if any textbook is seen as possibly
illegal
a growing number of hong kong authors
publishers
and bookstores are moving their
businesses abroad neither jimmy peng nor
raymond young
are ready to quit raymond's book is
called
to freedom that's what he wants to
practice despite the challenges
face and face it's frustrating but i
will try to publish it in hong kong
this book itself is a form of resistance
the only way to keep the freedom of
publication alive
is to exercise it here and not to
abandon the rights we deserve
but he's in a minority many more people
in hong kong are observing the situation
from the sidelines
to fearful now of beijing's clout to
speak up